[Music]
in this short video we're going to show
you how we constructed and animated a
pop-up book to explain Earth's tectonic
plates the supercontinent pangaea broke
apart 200 million years ago but the
pieces haven't stopped shifting although
with animation we can show this movement
easily with drawings we thought it'd be
more interesting to depict gigantic
sliding slabs of rock using a tangible
object that also moves and shifts and
the pop-up book idea was born to make
your own pop-up book you'll need some
basic paper tools such as scissors and
exacto knife glue double-sided scotch
tape a ruler a bone folder or other
creasing tool and of course some paper
for this lesson we first determined the
visual style by making illustrations and
deciding on the overall design colors
shapes and elements we wanted on each
page or spread you can have more
detailed illustrations but we wanted to
illustrate this lesson simply by playing
with shapes and colors when you
visualize your pop-up and choose a
visual style you will want to make a
bunch of good old pencil sketches on
paper and plan each movement for each
spread plan as much as you can all the
basic shapes and how they connect and
how you want them to move which parts
you want to pop up first challenge
yourself and explore multiple
possibilities of how your main element
on the spread can pop up for the next
step make a mock-up spread and see if
your masterful paper engineering ideas
translate from a sketch to the actual
prototype instead of using fancy paper
start with the cheap stuff and allow
yourself to make mistakes and
adjustments this prototype lets you see
how your preliminary sketches will come
to life you will want to first draw all
individual parts on a single sheet
including all your main pieces all the
supporting pieces and the folds you may
be surprised that there are only two
types of folds that can make your
elements pop up the way you want a step
fold
and a v-fold
here you can see how we used a step fold
to make each layer of the earth step out
then cut all your individual elements
and assemble using glue or double-sided
scotch tape
[Music]
through trial and error
make sure that all the elements shapes
and placements are moving the way you
imagined and that they fold properly
when closed and Ogun
[Music]
once your prototype is tested and
complete you can proceed to making the
final product in color draw or paint on
your main pop-up elements as you see fit
for this lesson we decided to just play
with simple shapes in different colors
to create the world of shifting
continents we imagined
[Music]
when we were planning each spread we
knew we wanted some elements to move
independently of the typical pop-up book
using slight manipulations and
animations we had to plan well but also
use a few tricks as always when you're
making stop-motion you may have to be
creative and use all sorts of unusual
tools and props to achieve the effect
that you want in this shot the birds had
to fly across and off the edge of the
book so we used fun tack to move the
clouds across the page once they left
the page they had to be trimmed to get
the illusion they flew off when the
pages of the book closed at the end we
had to flip each page supporting it in
each position long enough to be
photographed as an individual frame we
used binder clips wedges fun tack and
almost every handy little thing you can
think of once all the individual frames
were photographed we put them all
together and composite it to make our
pop-up book look like it's moving on its
own so now think of a special occasion
where you can surprise someone with your
own unique pop-up card or an entire
story that you want to tell and start
plotting the ins and outs of your pop-up
book
you
[Music]